we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail i got about the future of
independent media I gave had my name is
Steve I was wondering what you think
about the long-term future of
independent media like yours on YouTube
you've talked a lot recently about your
videos getting D monetized for basically
random reasons that don't make much
sense and I've seen other people having
similar issues and it seems like
ultimately shows like yours are reliant
on a platform that you don't control
that doesn't really have any
transparency and that's moving towards
this fear of anything they find
quote-unquote controversial which seems
like ultimately it's going to turn into
what what cable TV has has become and I
was wondering if you have any ideas
about finding alternatives to YouTube or
how to fight that on the platform so
listen here's the thing the thing about
alternatives to YouTube the audience is
on YouTube so if I say I'm switching to
some other minor player I can do that
maybe there's more transparency maybe
there's more control but unfortunately
there's no audience which we also need
so the the if if the situation we're in
today is one where we are slightly in it
we're in slightly less trouble today if
we lose all YouTube revenue than we were
two years ago when ad pocalypse 1.0 hit
why because we have more membership
support today so for me the the solution
is if there's programs that you like and
that you value support them if they have
a means to do so we have something
called membership which allows people to
do that because if enough people sign up
we can self host our videos we can sell
ads against our videos with our own
staff and if YouTube says it's over it
doesn't really affect us so the solution
is when people unthinkingly have a cable
subscription where you are funding
channels you dislike in some way your
funding Fox News when you have a cable
subscription and a couple bucks a month
could actually make a show that you like
completely sort of impervious to
platform attacks the monetization
targeted boycotts whatever that's the
opportunity and I think that that's
really the path forward we've got a
great bonus show for you today become a
member speaking of the benefits of being
a member and supporting the show become
a member become a patron and I will
speak to you on the members only bonus
show in just a couple of minutes